paris notre dame la baguette la france
quoi
l'empilement des clichés n'a pas
impressionné tony doré qu'on sent très
méticuleux dans son domaine la boulange
le stress du concours la chaleur celui
qui fut meilleur apprenti d'eure-et-loir
s'adapte tony se dit
compétiteurs
les cours viennent juste d'être allumée
donc du coup la température est pas
encore trop montée du coût 24 26 degrés
température optimale pour utiliser les
fermentations des levures au niveau de
la maniabilité la qualité de pâtes j'ai
rien à j'ai rien à dire c'était parfait
point une longueur de baguettes
identique vous aspect alvéolage la
compétition se joue sur 120 points pour
départager 6 cadors de la baguette
question de détails de nuances et de
facultés d'adaptation des artistes
disons une farine qui étaient neutres
ils ne savent pas à l'origine de cette
farine c'est les conditions différentes
le four est différent ils ont le choix
entre un feu assez vif un four puidoux
donc c'est chacun doit s'adapter d'après
les conditions les températures et la
cuisson juste avant d'enfourner il n'y a
pas que la chaleur qui montrent la
tension aussi quelques secondes de
cuisson de plus de moins influent sur le
croustillant et le poids de la bête
puissant rapide c'est le choix de notre
boulanger de luisant là on est à 18
heures à peu près de fermentation ce qui
fait qu'on va essayer de chercher un
maximum d'arômes pour pouvoir avoir une
baguette vraiment goûteuse avec beaucoup
de saveur et
c'est ce qui va c'est steve à plaire aux
clients et c'est ce qu'il faut toute
façon c'est ce qu'il faut sortir
aujourd'hui si on va dans dans le top 3
d'octroi monsieur prudence avec ses
baguette de tradition française tout
juste sorti du four tony doré a remporté
le concours national ce mercredi retenez
bien ce nom doré tony doré comme le bon
pain